hallo freunde der sonne ich bin es
wieder mal eure chemikerin des
vertrauens herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge wissenschaftlich geprüft
heute mit einem sehr viel gewünschten
thema nämlich aktivkohle ich hatte ja
auch schon davon mitbekommen aber der
hype ist realist ich dachte aktivkohle
wasser smoothies brötchen gesichtsmasken
zahnpasta eiscreme und da fragt man sich
doch was soll das die antwort der
hersteller lautet aktivkohle ist
antibakteriell entgiftend macht weiße
zähne und vieles mehr doch was sagt die
wissenschaft dazu das klären wir jetzt
dass wir mal wieder zeit für mich sein
ticket zu verteilen wir schauen uns drei
verschiedene anwendungen an aktivkohle
in essen und trinken aktivkohle in der
gesichtspflege und aktivkohle in der
zahnpflege disco fangen wir direkt an
mit aktivkohle in essen und trinken erst
mal aktiv kohle ist nicht giftig sie
besteht hauptsächlich aus kohlenstoff
der unverdaut ausgeschieden wird und
prinzipiell keine schäden anrichtet
prinzipiell deswegen setzen manche
kohlenstoff pulver einfach als farbstoff
ein weil menschen momentan einfach gerne
schwarze sachen essen und trinken und
aber über die farbe hinaus soll
aktivkohle ja dürfte binden und
entsorgen stimmt das überhaupt ja genau
dafür wird aktivkohle nämlich
medizinisch bei akuten vergiftungen
eingesetzt gift moleküle sind meistens
größere moleküle die auch aus
kohlenstoff bestehen also nicht aus
reinem aber sie sind aus dem kohlenstoff
gerüst aufgebaut und zwischen den gift
molekül und der aktivkohle bestehen
schwache anziehungskräfte die heißen van
der waals kräfte sagen wir das ist die
oberfläche der aktivkohle das ist ein
gift molekül dann kann die aktivkohle
das gift molekül
wer van der waals kräfte anziehen diesen
vorgang dieses anziehen an die
oberfläche nennt man absorption da die
kohle einfach wieder unverdaut
ausgeschieden wird können die
absorbierten gift moleküle direkt mit
ausgeschieden werden funktioniert so was
dann auch mit normaler grillkohle
grillkohle ist auch kohlenstoffhaltige
bisschen andere zusammensetzung aber der
wichtige unterschied ist ein anderer
das aktive an aktivkohle ist diese
schwammartige von aktivkohle enthält
ganz viele sehr sehr kleine poren im
nanobereich was dazu führt dass
aktivkohle eine unglaublich große
oberfläche hat er stellt euch jetzt
vorher wer hilft keine löcher dann hätte
ich quasi nur diese oberfläche aber
jetzt durch die löcher habe ich jetzt
überall bei jedem loch an der loch
innenwand auch nochmal oberfläche wo
eben genau das wo die absorption
passieren kann so passte auf ein gramm
aktivkohle kann bis zu 2.000
quadratmeter oberfläche haben das heißt
viel gramm aktivkohle haben eine
oberfläche von ungefähr einem
fußballfeld und da als option eben nur
an der oberfläche passiert und da diese
wechselwirkung diese van der waals
kräfte nicht besonders stark sind ist es
eben genau diese riesige oberfläche die
aktivkohle überhaupt erst wirksam macht
also ja aktivkohle kann gifte binden
dafür ist es jetzt noch zu früh
entschuldigung denn die chemie ist hier
noch nicht zu ende
giftstoffe können an aktivkohle
absorbiert werden aber wisst ihr was
noch alles absolviert werden kann so
ziemlich alles vitamine antioxidantien
alle möglichen nährstoffe die wir eben
nicht und verdaut ausscheiden möchten
sondern die wir gerne in unserem körper
aufnehmen möchten die werden auch an die
aktivkohle absorbiert ist jetzt nicht so
dass aktivkohle der ober magnet für
absolut alles ist es kommt schon darauf
an wie stark diese van der waals kräfte
sind aber diese adoption ist schon
ziemlich unspezifisch also die
aktivkohle kann nicht unterscheiden ob
das jetzt ein giftstoff ist oder ein
vitamin wenn man jetzt gerade eine akute
vergiftung hat dann ist es natürlich
herzlich egal was für vitamine daran
gehen hauptsache das gift geht raus aber
wenn man jetzt regelmäßig aktiv kohle
über essen oder trinken zu sich nimmt
ohne dass man gerade eine vergiftung hat
dann würdest du dazu dass man sich
irgendwelche nährstoffe selbst vor
enthält außerdem kann ich nicht oft
genug wiederholen wer eine
funktionierende leber und niere hat hat
alles was er zum geht ochs braucht das
weist ihr die talks ist einfach nur ein
marketing scam der höchstens euren
geldbeutel von scheinen entgiftet aber
ich bin immer noch nicht fertig auch
medikamente könnten absorbiert werden
stellt euch mal vor ihre antibabypille
wirklich mehr weil die hormone
aktivkohle absorbiert wurden schwanger
durch smoothie also das ist bisher nur
eine befürchtung eine logische eine
berechtigte aber es gibt hierzu keine
forschung da aktivkohle ja sonst
medizinisch für diese akuten
vergiftungen genutzt wird das ist gut
untersucht aber so ein alltäglicher
gebrauch ist eben nicht gar nicht gut
untersucht sodass wir auch gar nicht
sagen können wie viel zum beispiel von
der anti baby pille jetzt daran
absorbieren würde aber obwohl es diese
forschung nicht gibt sind manche
hersteller aus mysteriösen gründen da
erstaunlich sicher hier so einen effekt
zu seinem aktivkohle wasser hemmt es die
wirkung von medikamenten nein das ist
ausgeschlossen
du müsstest schon 100 flaschen von
blackwater trinken aber dann hast du
wohl andere probleme hat schön csi für
keinerlei wissenschaftliche
anhaltspunkte also
von wegen ausgeschlossen wie gesagt es
gibt keine forschung dazu man kann hier
nur schätzen das haben sie hier wohl
gemacht und kam so auf ihre 100 flaschen
schätzelein ihr müsst euch doch
entscheiden entweder absorbiert ein
schwarzes wasser gifte die talks dann
absorbiert es aber auch medikamente oder
man muss erst 100 flaschen dafür trinken
ihr könnt ich sein gift wird mal los
aber medikamente
nein ausgeschlossen also aktivkohle in
essen und trinken im norden prüft nur
vegan aktivkohle und skin care
hier wird dasselbe prinzip beworben
aktivkohle soll
schmutz und fette und giftstoffe hier
kommen soll sei alles möglich
absorbieren und die haut zu reinigen
prinzipiell kann man sich ja nach allem
was ich gerade über aktivkohle erzählt
habe durchaus vorstellen dass aktivkohle
sachen absorbiert und so die haut
reinigt wie gut und gesund das jetzt
aber für die haut ist dazu gibt es quasi
keine forschung was schon von vornherein
ein problem ist weil diese hersteller
jetzt irgendwelche behauptungen
aufstellen mit neuen produkten und neuen
inhaltsstoffen für die es keinerlei
wissenschaftliche basis gibt ich kann
jetzt nur versuchen aus meiner sicht
also aus sicht einer chemikerin zu
schauen was ist jetzt chemisch logisch
und was nicht hi
die chemischen eigenschaften von
aktivkohle sind das eine und die ich
habe mal das mechanische handling ist
das andere ich sagte es war ich kenne
aktivkohle auch aus dem labor also
stellt euch vor ihr habt ein kolben und
dass eine flüssigkeit drin also
lösungsmittel unten stoff den jetzt
gerade hergestellt hat jetzt ist da aber
noch ein zweiter stoff drin eine
verunreinigung und die möchtet ihr
aussagen
wenn ihr jetzt glück gehabt und der
stoff und die verunreinigung sind in
ihren eigenschaften so verschieden
kann es sein dass aktivkohle helfen kann
weil zum beispiel aktivkohle die
verunreinigung absorbiert euren stoff
aber nicht wenn das der fall ist könnt
ihr einfach einen löffel aktiv pohl
reingeben dann höre dir das ganze eine
zeit lang geschüttelt dass in der zeit
lang und dann nachdem die verunreinigung
absorbiert wurde kann man die aktivkohle
mit der verunreinigung ab filtriert und
dann kommt bleibt das reine produkt
zurück der grund warum ist gerade der
zeta willst ich kenne das nur so dass
man für diese absorption bisschen zeit
braucht ja also man muss das rühren oder
schütteln und das für mehrere minuten
lang ist das ordentlich funktioniert
wenn ich das jetzt auf so eine
gesichtsmaske übertrage die
wahrscheinlich auch noch trocken wird
nach einer zeit dann gibt es ja auch
keine flüssigkeit die durch diese poren
der aktivkohle durchfließen kann
es gibt generell kaum bewegung des
ganzen recht trockene statische
angelegenheit hier ist einfach maske auf
haut und ich kann mir einfach nicht
vorstellen dass so diese absorption
besonders gut funktioniert also es wird
wahrscheinlich besser funktionieren wir
mal eher so eine art als gibt es
bestimmt auch zum reinigungsschaum hat
oder in peking wo man das gesicht
wirklich eine längere zeit am besten
minuten lang so im wasser hat und dass
dann die ganze zeit trug aber selbst
dann fällt mir keine chemisch logische
erklärung ein warum aktivkohle jetzt
schmutz so viel besser entfernen sollte
als stinknormale tenside also als
stinknormale seite zu zensieren und
mitzählen wasser gibt es hier auch noch
ein extra video also ich sehe auf jeden
fall keine logisch erklärbaren vorteile
für anwendung von aktivkohle in der
kosmetik und ist geprägt gesagt
keinerlei wissenschaftliche basis für
all diese behauptungen des wegen nada
prüft und zuletzt aktivkohle in der
zahnpflege also dann aktivkohle
vielleicht farbstoffe absorbieren und so
weitere zähne machen und hilft
aktivkohle irgendwie gegen karies
letzteres ist eher unwahrscheinlich wenn
man weiß wie karies entsteht also gibt
es auch hier ein ganzes video wir hatten
zu diesem zahnpasta video sogar ein
folge video gemacht weil es in den
kommentaren so viel diskussionen über
floride gab und ob die das gehirn
schädigen und für dieses video für ide
verhalten das gehirn sind wir nominiert
entschuldigung für diesen einschub aber
wir sind nominiert für den fast v1
wettbewerb 2018
und es gibt neben der dem jurypreis auch
noch ein publikumspreis und wenn ihr uns
da helfen möchte
dann schaut unbedingt die ent card so
aber jetzt geht's weiter letztes jahr
kam dieser wissenschaftliche artikel
raus ein literatur review über kohle in
der zahnpflege man hat zuerst geschaut
was hersteller von solchen kohle zahlen
produkten behaupten also effektiv gegen
karies noch die zähne weise
antibakteriell und so weiter und dann
haben sie sämtliche wissenschaftliche
veröffentlichungen zur kohle und
zahnpflege durch geschaut um zu sehen
wie die hersteller überhaupt auf diese
behauptungen kommen
kurz gesagt über die wissenschaft sind
sie nicht drauf gekommen denn dieses
review zeigt dass es bisher keine
kontrollierten klinischen studien gibt
die einen vorteil von kohle in
zahnpflegeprodukten
irgendwie belegen jetzt ist es aber
durchaus denkbar dass aktivkohle die
zähne aufhält aber experten beobachten
diese ganzen instagram und youtube
videos sieht das immer sehr eindrücklich
demonstrieren mit sorge weil dieser
vorgang sehr aggressiv sein kann
aktivkohle kann das zahnfleisch reizen
oder schädigen und auch das ganze
schrubben mit der aktivgruppe also das
physikalische reiten kann auch für den
zahnschmelz eventuell zu viel seien auf
lange sicht deswegen kann ich nur sagen
vorsicht freunde der sonne ich meine
schaut meine zähne an alles was ihr
dafür braucht es eine guten weißabgleich
glaubt nicht immer alles was euch so auf
verpackungen angepriesen wird im norden
prüft falls ihr lust habt uns zu
unterstützen
beim publikumspreis für den
parteienwettbewerb dann könnt ihr das
tool unter diesem video dort werden
nämlich noch bis zum 14 oktober wieder
like und jeder kommentar gezählt und
jeder kommentar der eine diskussion
anstößt sogar doppelt und war es hier
vorschläge habt was ich in zukunft
wissenschaftlich prüfen kann
schreibe es in die kommentare wir sehen
uns nächsten donnerstag bis dahin sicher